mary kate olsen in a rush to get a
divorce after a nasty split
and there are hundreds of millions of
dollars at stake
brutal
that's how our source describes mary
kate split it's apparently so bad the 33
year old has taken the unusual step of
requesting an emergency court order
to divorce her husband of four years 50
year old olivier sarkozy
right now in new york city they are not
processing
any divorces so anyone that wants to get
divorced in new york city
basically has to wait around and it
appears
that mary kate didn't want to wait
around in court papers mary kate writes
this application is an emergency because
my husband expects me to move out of our
home
in the middle of new york city being on
pause due to covid19
it looks to me like her attorney is
using a clever way
to try to get her divorce through i
think it has
a very low likelihood of working
but you certainly have to give credit to
mary kate and her attorney for trying
a source tells e.t their relationship
was a happy one and they truly seem to
enjoy each other's company
which is why it's all the more shocking
to hear how contentious things sound
right now
there are millions at stake olivier a
french banker is worth an estimated 60
million dollars
he's 17 years older than mary kate and
the half brother of former french
president nicholas sarkozy
mary kate along with her twin sister
ashley are together said to be worth
a staggering 500 million dollars
so how did mary kay get so rich i play
with puppies
well we were there at the beginning the
olsen twins were reportedly making 80
000 per episode on full house after it
became a hit
you were pretty little when you started
on the show right yeah how old were you
nine months old nine months old mary
kate still gets residuals
as teenagers the twins made millions
with successful fashion lines and
they became targets of the paparazzi it
becomes really dangerous first of all
and everybody wants a good story
mary kate's last on screen role was for
the movie beastly
we were on set for my birthday
it was it was nice it uh reminded me of
my childhood
the actress turned designer is
reportedly asking for the enforcement of
an ironclad prenup
i mean the fact that she has a prenup
doesn't necessarily
prevent him from taking anything that
she's earned
following the marriage but it's
certainly the prenup is certainly going
to factor in to what happens during the
divorce
proceedings and what he gets and what
she gets